hey you guys
time for another movie retrospective so
this one uh was actually in the patreon
poll and it was tied with another one
so i flipped a coin to see which one we
were gonna do and it ended up being this
one which i've been wanting to do for a
really long time
this is mask of the red death from 1964.
pretty good movie yeah directed by roger
corman and starring
vincent price i mean vincent price
it's a classic it definitely is it's
cool um easily
my favorite of all of roger corman's uh
edgar allan poe
adaptations uh it's certainly the best
looking one
yeah good color palette and uh you know
i didn't actually know this until
i started because i've seen this movie a
bunch of times like starting when i was
a kid but i didn't actually know this
until i started researching the movie
but the cinematographer on this was
nicholas roig who would uh become quite
famous later on
as a director in his own right uh he did
don't look now
one of my favorite movies from the 1970s
uh he did performance i believe he did
the man who fell to earth with david
bowie
he's made like a [ __ ] ton of really good
movies so you can really see
like his visual eye and this is like
really really gorgeous
right these movies always kind of
reminded me of
kind of like an american version of a
hammer horror film oh they definitely
are just not quite as boobalicious
oh hammer was about showing
boobs this had this had a little bit of
boobage in it yeah just not as focused
on it not as focused not as not as
boob-centric
or boob focused yeah it's
the very russ meyers is about there in a
british kind of way
yeah yeah well and i should say too that
this particular movie
a large pr uh proportion of the cast
were british because they
shot it in the uk i think this was only
one of two because this was the seventh
of roger corman's eight edgar allan poe
adaptations i think we did
house of usher like a while back um it's
weird because
i put this on the list initially because
shutter had added
almost all of them i think but then when
i went to watch it
again last night like before recording
this it was gone
so i had to uh rent it on amazon prime
but it was only 3.99 so
i wasn't like sad or anything but it was
just weird how it was there and then it
was not there i guess the rights
i think what happened was the rights
reverted to someone else because i think
a special edition blu-ray of this just
came out like a
like a month and a half ago so i imagine
that they only let them show it until
like the good [ __ ] because they want
everybody to like buy the special
edition
so basically like i said this is the
seventh of the eight uh
adaptations the eighth one i believe was
tomb of ligeia
and those two last ones were shot in the
uk
um to take advantage of you know various
tax breaks and [ __ ] like that
and uh but but to do that you had to use
like if it was a certain percentage of
the cast had to be british
like you could have an american star you
could have a couple people in there that
were americans but they mostly had to be
brits
so that's why you know hazel court is in
this who was in i think she was in a
bunch of hammer movies too actually
she's probably the most boobalishes one
good old hammer
i tell you man they like they love them
some boobs down there
over there you know i can understand it
though man well yeah that's like right
up your alley
you probably fit right in hell yeah if
you're gonna make a movie
put a [ __ ] boobs in it a whole bunch
of them guys will come see it it's
called getting asses and seats
you know what i i feel like tom should
make a movie just called
boobs the movie boobs the movie and it
would just be like wall-to-wall boobs
like the whole
there might be a plot in there somewhere
but it's and maybe an explosion but it's
like
it's just mostly just a parade of yeah
jiggling
and jiggling poop
that's genetic you know what i mean i
don't know what it is
that's just something about boobs yeah
well actually like i said in this one
it's like an ass but it's in the front
yeah
it's your front butt i guess so yeah
it's something genetic you know
in certain guys i guess you know yeah i
mean to greater or lesser extent
they are kind of fascinating the way
they hang there globularly
look at that look at that now she's
teasing me
now she's teased me well you do actually
get to see hazel cord in this one she
don't get to see
her boobs really oh you kind of can see
him through this kind of
diaphanous like yeah thing that she has
okay it's just been
hammer consistently takes it to another
level though yeah and just like hanging
up yeah
they weren't bashful about it yeah they
knew exactly why you were watching this
movie this one was a little subtler
although i will say that you do get to
see hazel court
uh branding an upside down crucifix onto
her
boob yeah under her decolletage if you
want to call it that
so yeah uh so basically this one uh shot
in the uk like i said this was the first
one that done that like roger corman
very famously
these last two poe pictures that he shot
in the uk
he complained a little bit because he
said look if i was shooting these in the
u.s it would take like three weeks
because he had like his crew he knew
everybody knew what they wanted to do
they kind of got in there and got [ __ ]
done he's like in the uk man he's like
they gotta like [ __ ] take tea breaks
and it's like and it took two weeks
longer than it would take in the u.s
because he thought they were
kind of slow which i thought was kind of
funny however
i will say like i said you do have a lot
of british people in this
movie which is great also the sets that
they used in this which they redressed a
little bit
from if you guys have ever seen the
movie beckett
with i think peter o'toole was in it we
i remember watching it in high school
it's really really good it was based on
the uh on the play
and they used they redressed some of the
sets from that uh so
because the sets in this are gorgeous
i love the visuals of this movie it's
just like so sumptuous
and colorful and everything's all
colored tiles yeah it's great
and honestly i've seen some critics
say that this you know
roger corman's po pictures might have
been an influence on
mario bava dario argento like for that
saturated like super colorful look
because you know mario bava made the
first
giallo movie but the first one was black
and white
so blood and black lace which was kind
of the first color one that didn't come
out until a few years after this
so could be i don't know
now this movie i thought they did
something really kind of interesting
with it i always love when vincent price
plays a villain
because man he leans into that [ __ ] it's
like he has i guess some people would
say it was
can't be but i don't know i i just
really really
like the way he kind of hands it up when
he plays a villain you can tell he's
having a [ __ ] ball with it
kind of like he didn't dr phoebe yeah
like all those kind of movies and
because he played a villain i guess in a
lot of these uh
the poe movies but he just really really
seems to relish
playing a villain and he's really having
a lot of fun with it and
in this one he is pretty [ __ ] evil
so just like in the short story and like
i said i'll go a little bit more into
because this is actually kind of based
on two
post short stories not just mask of the
red death but vincent price plays
uh you know prince prospero who um
you know in the story he's a [ __ ]
and it's basically
you know the story uh by edgar allan poe
is very very short it's only what like
three pages or something like that it's
really really you know
it's really short so to expand it out
into a whole story you kind of have to
add
you know some more of some other
elements it does have the element of
prince prospero and all of his kind of
decadent courtiers
partying it up like in this big castle
while
uh you know the the plague ravages all
the peasants outside
um you know the with the the message
being that you
even though you have all this money and
you have you think you're protected from
it you're actually not because it's a
disease
and it will get you in the end i like
though that one thing they added to this
which actually kind of
it's not in the story but i like that it
kind of made it more
it made it more realistic that the
courtiers would actually
think that they would be protected from
the plague because in this version of
the story prince prospero played by
vincent price
is a satanist and basically his whole
deal the reason why he's doing all this
decadent [ __ ]
and cruel [ __ ] in his um you know castle
other than just being an [ __ ] is that
he thinks that he's serving
satan and by you know and going on from
that
him being like in satan's good books he
thinks well that just protects him and
that protects everyone else from the
disease so i think that was like a good
thing that they added to the story
because it does make
it does make it more um you know story
wise it makes it more realistic that
people be like oh you know you're
protected by the devil
we can't get the disease if we come here
and we're under your protection
you know and by you know and by
extension were under satan's protection
so that kind of like makes more sense
why people would come there
so basically like i said they they
establish right out the gate that
prospero
is just like this giant [ __ ] [ __ ]
because he comes through in his fancy
little carriage in this
little village and almost runs over a
baby like someone because he's just like
[ __ ] that baby whatever peasant baby
and um somebody has to like run and like
you know snatch it out of the way
and then he's like oh the [ __ ] going
on here these peasants blah blah
and those so then there's this um really
young girl
whose name is francesca and uh basically
he kind of takes a shine to her because
she's uh very pious and she's very
innocent
and his whole thing is he really likes
to corrupt the innocent because he
thinks that satan likes that
so that's just something that he likes
to do probably does well yeah you would
think
you would think that would be satan's
bag right there i'm glad some corrupt
some [ __ ]
that's right yeah so that's what he's
planning on doing so basically he
snatches his girl because she's all
pretty and redheaded and stuff
and then the first thing for his
entertainment he's like okay well
we captured your boyfriend geno and your
dad whose i think name is
ludovico like ludovico technique from
clockwork orange just saying
but um so he and basically he tells her
well you have to choose like which one i
kill
and she's like [ __ ] that brush like i
don't want to do that and so there's
this big altercation and then
prince prospero finds out that the red
death i.e the plague
has come to the village there's this old
woman and she dies of it and then he's
like okay well we need to get the [ __ ]
out of here but i'm taking this chick
with me
and i'm also taking her boyfriend and
her dad as
leverage so i can get her to do without
do what i want because i'll
you know hold that over her head that
they you know that they're there uh
so he basically keeps her captive at the
castle
kind of holding the fate of her
boyfriend and her dad
over her head while he's sort of talking
about his satanic
beliefs and like trying to corrupt her
get her
to kind of go along with his things and
she's very naive
the one thing about this i will say
though that it's like i'm not really
sure
because the thing that happens at the
end where she seems like she's going
along with it i don't know if she's
really going along with it because
she's like oh intriguing and she's just
really naive and she's just like what's
this satan biz this seems pretty cool
or if she's just doing it so make it so
she can escape
i mean because she does try to escape
later on and i think she does actually
escape but there are there's like some
weird like unclear things where it seems
like
where it almost seems like she's kind of
into it i don't know it's really weird
but yeah so um hazel court is
already at the castle and she is
prince prospero's wife mistress consort
whatever
she's also a satanist like i said she
does the whole boob thing with the
upside down cross
like with the brand or whatever and uh
she's not too happy about this younger
perky or
red-headed chick turn it up in the
castle they tend to do that for some
reason they get jealous i don't get it
you don't get it i don't get it i can't
understand
it well that's well i mean she's a oh
i'm getting thrown over for somebody
like younger and cuter that's i guess
that's the fear that uh
well yeah women go through well yeah
they don't want to be replaced
well yeah you don't want to you know
you're going to be like left like even
with a whole bunch of cats although
actually that sounds kind of nice
my mind will just live with a bunch of
cats he was going to throw
he wasn't going to throw her out though
he's just adding to his collection
i guess so yeah and like her wives
satanic mormon [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
but that's the thing well i guess what
it was because you have to say you have
to think that
uh hazel court's character whose name is
juliana she
is also a satanist and she's all about
it man she looks like goes in there and
does all the rituals it's like
i want to be betrothed to satan and
everything so she's on board
with the satanism so i guess maybe
prospero is just kind of like well i
corrupted that one like that worked way
better than i was planning
so it's like it's not fun anymore
because it's like oh well now she's evil
too
uh so now i need a good one like because
it's more fun to like [ __ ] up a good one
than just have like an evil one so i'm
guessing that's what it's worth
uh but yeah so that happens so so
there's this whole thing where he's
kind of going through the [ __ ] and like
talking about satan and everything now
one thing i will say too
that not only i mentioned this earlier
but this is not only an adaptation of
mask of the red death they actually did
something quite clever
because the short story is very short
and uh you'd really have to expand it
out like to make a feature-length film
out of it
so what they decided to do instead of
just adding a bunch of random [ __ ]
was they actually added a subplot that
is almost
entirely the edgar allen poe story hop
frog
which i thought was a very interesting
thing to do because hopfrog
is about a person with dwarfism
and he works at the court of this really
[ __ ]
king or prince or something like that so
it's kind of in the same setting already
uh he has a little girlfriend who is
also a little dwarf named esmeralda who
is a beautiful little dancer
um she actually pisses off one of the
courtiers and he
smacks her uh which makes uh
the which makes hop frog although in the
movie they call him hop toad i'm not
really sure why but his name is hot frog
and uh it makes him really really mad so
he decides he's gonna get like this
really really hardcore revenge
in the sense that i think now in the
movie version i think it's only one guy
that he uh kind of tricks him he's like
hey when we do the masquerade ball
tonight
wear this gorilla suit and act like a
gorilla it'll be [ __ ] hilarious and
like everyone will be super into it
and uh then by the way i'm not telling
you this part but i'm gonna like tie you
up to the chandelier and then
set you on fire and burn you alive
because you're a douche
um so that does happen so it's only like
one guy in the movie but i think in the
story it was
several guys and he like chained them
all together and like set him on fire
and then him and
esmeralda got the [ __ ] out of there so i
kind of like that they added that
because like i said the setting of it
was
similar um and so it kind of made like a
nice addition also the dude that plays
the dude that gets
burned alive in the gorilla suit is uh
his name is alfredo like fettuccine
alfredo
that's how i remembered it and he is
played by what's that dude's name
uh patrick mcgee or something like that
he was the same guy
that played the writer in a clockwork
orange
the guy that got his like the wife got
raped and murdered and then he's yeah
it's that he's been in tons of other
[ __ ]
but every time i see him i was like like
a raj guy you know what i mean i think
he's like a shakespearean
actor like he started out as a stage
actor
so i thought that was pretty cool the
way they incorporated those two stories
you know with a similar setting into one
thing now the first time i saw this
movie
when i was a kid i remember because
mask of the red death um along with the
telltale heart
are my very favorite edgar allan poe
stories
i remember the first time that i saw
this movie being really disappointed
that they didn't go that they didn't do
the seven chambers
in the story you know what i'm saying i
mean now i can appreciate
constraints blah blah blah so really
they only did
four of them they do like the yellow
there's a yellow room a purple room
a white room and then the black room
like with the red window
in the story there's three more there's
like an orange one a green one and a
blue one i think
so i was always kind of sad that they
didn't put that in there but
you know i can see why they didn't now
like i said budgetary constraints and
then
they have they had the way they had the
set
done they had them all like in a row so
they have these really really great
shots where
you know the the camera would like track
like through the rooms like while they
walked through them and i thought that
was really cool
and if you were gonna do that for like
six or seven rooms that would probably
just get really tiresome so
i guess that's why they didn't do it
other than it being too expensive to
make seven [ __ ] rooms for like three
[ __ ] scenes or however much it was in
there
so yeah so basically what ends up
happening i think there's
kind of um you know vincent price kind
of cackles around and he's like being
really evil
and he ends up i think he ends up
killing
um or wounding no i guess he does get
killed the dad of francesca because they
do this whole thing where it's kind of
like
russian roulette but with poison daggers
instead of a gun
the dad ends up dying so she tries to
like endear herself
to vincent price by pretending to be all
into this satan
[ __ ] and then um trying to
help her boyfriend gino escape now
she thinks like juliana comes to her and
is like hey i'll help you let your
boyfriend out because you know
i i don't like that you're here because
you know vincent price is looking at you
and not me
so get the [ __ ] out of here but turns
out that juliana is evil too
and she kind of [ __ ] her over and tells
the guards and everything like that
however just as in the story mask of the
red death
uh the red death shows up at the party
now i really like the way
they shot this like the dude that comes
in there
and he's got all the red [ __ ] on and
it's just like in the story where
although i don't like that they didn't
incorporate the clock as much
like there is a clock in it but there's
no clock in the black room like there
was in the story which was another thing
that kind of bummed me out a little bit
but whatever it's just
so long since i've read that story i do
remember that clock was there a bunch of
colored glass
too yeah well every single room was like
decorated like i said
it was a suite and there was seven rooms
you could see the ones like through
there like the way
the story is like really really great
like visually
i mean you could easily make it that was
poe messing with those drugs again
well yeah psychedelic
and there and definitely you know what
in this movie there is one scene
which and i feel like a lot of movies
that came out in the 60s especially
roger corman ones the edgar allen poems
always had a
and then the acid kicked in moment
this one has that when juliana is doing
her
uh satanic ritual you know to kind of
say hey
satan like i'm gonna be your bride now
or whatever and there's this really
weird sequence where everything goes
like that and then it like turns blue
and then she's like laying on a slab
like with this dress that you can kind
of see through
and she's laying there and then all of
these
people come in there and they like do
kind of dance i guess they're all
supposed to be like warriors or demons
or something like that but it's really
kind of weird because
one of them is like an african tribal
warrior and then one of them is like a
i don't know if he's supposed to be like
a samurai but it's kind of like a white
guy
with like weird makeup honestly it's
just like it's very bizarre they just
use with the head
i guess and then so they so they're all
just kind of all dancing around and
doing their thing and then they all like
pretend to stab her and she's like
laying there screaming and stuff so i
guess
that's supposed to represent all of
satan's demons
or you know three or four of them i
don't remember how many it was but um
kind of taking her soul finally or
taking her
last bits of it i don't know but it was
just kind of like i feel like there was
a lot of these sort of like acid trippy
kind of scenes in the 60s that's what i
mean
um even some gela movies had that like a
little bit later on where they would
kind of have
like all the colors of the dark had kind
of scenes like that where they were
really [ __ ] surreal and [ __ ]
so i feel like there's a lot of that
going on this movie in particular
i think is real like i said all of
all of um you know corman's poe movies
are good
but i think this one is the best
just because it's so beautiful to look
at i mean like all
the sets are gorgeous um the costumes
are gorgeous
just like the way it's shot is beautiful
but um some people have said too that
you can
actually see because as i said nicholas
roig was the um
cinematographer on this and he said it's
and everyone said it's like really funny
that
there's this whole sequence in this
movie where the red death like comes to
the masquerade party and is like walking
through the thing and vincent price is
like running after him like through the
rooms
they're like oh just like in don't look
now like donald sutherland chasing after
the
the little figure in the red raincoat
you know what i mean it was just it's
very much
uh kind of a prototype of that which i
think is really cool
but yeah so the red death comes in there
and
it's funny because vincent price
initially
i keep calling him vincent price it was
his character's name is prospero but
ever it's been surprised come on
so vincent price uh thinks that the red
death is there and that he's the devil
so he's kind of like hey devil man
what's up like i've been doing all this
[ __ ] for you and it's like look at all
the debauchery that's going on it's like
all these courtiers in here pretending
they're animals and all those [ __ ]
like
words and [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] is
going on can't show orgies in the 60s
but that was what was implied
so so he was just kind of like hey man
i'm your biggest fan or whatever
and then the red death is like brah i'm
i'm not the devil it's like i'm i'm deaf
i don't i don't even know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about and it's like we
don't care we're just gonna kill
everybody including you
um so so i really really like that they
had like the
the dude that did the voiceover for the
red death was really cool and he had
that weird
mask on with all the fringe and [ __ ]
then he's like take your mask out take
him and then it was vincent price's face
because he's like you know you'll see
the face of death like when your time
has come
and then he's like no don't kill me i'm
you kill everyone else but it's like i'm
wonderful and of course
i can't be killed because satan told me
that i couldn't be killed or something
like that i'm like
i don't know if you feel like satan
makes all kind of promises i don't know
why
anybody ever like listens to him but
yeah so
so he ends up getting killed francesca
ends up getting away
all of the irritating courtiers well hi
there pookie okay showed up
pookie has showed up and she did you
watch mask of the red death pokey
she's watched some of it yeah she did
watch some of it was it scaly it's not
it's actually not scary
um and i think that i think roger corman
said
maybe vincent price said too that this
was their favorite of the eight
po pictures that they had done although
um
it didn't do as well as some of the
other ones and samuel arkhoff
uh from american international pictures
who was the
very famously distributor for these
thought that maybe it's
well it wasn't scary or gory enough and
it was too arty farty quote-unquote yeah
and then that so audiences didn't like
it as much
but honestly of all of them i'd have to
watch all of them
because you know i've seen some of the
ones recently like house of usher and
stuff
but some of the some of them it's been a
long time since i've seen it
seen them i remember premature burial
being really good
pitting the pendulum being really good
but i feel like this one
is my favorite just because it looks so
fantastic
and it doesn't even matter that it's not
scary or that it's not
you know what i mean it's it's just just
such a visual feast for the eyes and it
doesn't have to be scary and like i said
[ __ ]
vincent price being a villain is always
[ __ ] great
and i'm just never gonna get tired of
that so it's like it doesn't even have
to be scary because he's just having
such a great time in the role and
everything's just so
gorgeous that i'm really not even
bothered that it's not bloody or
anything like that at all but and it's
just like entertaining for the kind of
movie that yeah
it's just like a really entertaining
cool looking movie and like i said i
really
like that they incorporated that they
didn't just add a bunch of [ __ ] to
the story to fl to
kind of pat it out but they actually
added another post story
in with it that sort of like fit in and
fit in with the same theme
so that shows me that they were kind of
like thinking although i must say that
i feel like roger corman as notoriously
uh quick as he liked to work and you
know and cheap as he liked to work
he actually went through i believe at
least
five different screenwriters on this
just because he had been wanting to do
mask of the red death
from like 1960 and he just couldn't
get a script that he liked he kept
getting a dude he's like hey write a
script based on mask of the red death
and then he was like nah i like it
and then he would have somebody do it so
it took him like four years
to get a version that he liked and i
don't even think he liked that satanic
angle at first
but i honestly think that that's a good
thing that
to add to the story because like i said
it makes it more
believable why all these people would be
rushing there for protection
i mean because it you wouldn't just be
protected by prince prospero's wealth
and you know this big you know imposing
castle that he had
but you'd also be protected or so you
think by
infernal forces or like satan's power so
you can see why you know [ __ ] would get
around about that it's like you'll be
safe in there because it's under satan's
protection
so you know so i like that they added
that aspect to it i thought it was very
clever
but yeah definitely this is probably
not only my favorite of the roger corman
po pictures maybe
my favorite poe adaptation ever just the
way it looks um
like i said mask of the red death along
with telltale heart are my favorite
post stories i even did a whole board
game based on mask of the red death with
the
with the rooms that you have to get out
of there like before the red death gets
you and [ __ ] like that
so um it's you know it's a story that
made a lot of impact on me when i was
growing up and just like the whole
visual of it is really appealing to me
so obviously anytime you do anything
like that and you
do it all beautiful and technicolor like
this one
like i said it doesn't have to be scary
just get some good actors in there get
some good set design and
i'm pretty happy with it look at little
pokey
yep look at her little sweet face since
all her eyes are closed
smile eyes are closed i'm so glad you
came in to be on the show pokey
you very rarely sit still long enough to
be on the show because she's always
starting poops
moving around yeah yes starring poops
guest starring the pokey i'm going to
put that in the
in the title when i put this up too but
yeah so
i know tom hasn't said like a great deal
all that much to say about it
from you know actually
you like it it was entertaining it's not
very scary
no it's not it's nowhere near to me it's
nowhere near as good as say like
that hammer horror carmilla flick well
yeah that's the lesbian family
yeah it means you know of course
obviously lesbian vampires are gonna
like
pretty much everything it is a movie
[Laughter]
at least it's a movie at least it's a
movie yeah but i really really like it
so like i said if you're into 60 [ __ ] if
you're into edgar allan poe if you love
vincent price and you haven't seen this
somehow
then uh probably you should see it
although you can't see it on shutter
anymore because they just
took it right off and i didn't even
notice they took it away but you can run
it on amazon prime for 3.99
at least as of this recording so yeah go
and
check it out and we will see on the next
one bye